you know
outtakes on patreon.com trash taste of
course
yeah of course of course right dude
guys i thought we were professionals
we've been doing the hay fever seasons
[ __ ] we've been doing this for almost
like two years now we should we should
be on this man we should be on this
[ __ ] i'm sorry i'm sorry she's a vine
boom sound effect
i'm just yeah i've i've been just hay
fever's been kicking my ass this season
yeah all of a sudden i hate it yeah and
especially like now when you're
sniffling on a train and you just see
like all these like
hey yo
some japanese guys have like these
the these most aggressive gravelly
coughs dude oh yeah i don't know how
they have
yeah
deep and coveted season as well you're
just like you're on high [ __ ] alert
yeah i'm like one of those guards metal
gear solid and like the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] alert pops up and i'm just like
oh
like i actually saw uh at my local
bookstore they they were selling these
pins during the pandemic like in the
middle of the pandemic that just said
like during a hay fever season it was a
pin that just said don't worry i have
hay fever
[Music]
and so like people would like if there
was sniffling on the train you'd just
like show off the badge and be like i
don't have covered guys
but what if you had covered and you
bought that anyway just to be like guys
it's hey
yeah like because i remember
because um
i also had like a little bit of hay
fever but also i remember one week i
just got like a cough or something and
getting a cough during the pandemic time
is like the worst right because normally
normally it feels bad
to cough in public anyway but like
you're you're like when you have like
just it's just like a dry cough
especially you have to like just you're
so conscious about it right yeah about
like how often you're coughing and it
just makes the cough like when you're
thinking about it it just makes the
cough ten times worse
you know what i mean yeah and like
especially on like public transport you
just i i remember like normally
normally going going to my old place it
would be stressful if i needed to take a
[ __ ] right
you know when you're like holding it in
i was like holding in this like this
[ __ ] cough and like [ __ ] like
spacing this cough out that i had for
like a good 40 minutes or however long
that journey was yeah and i don't know
if anyone around me like noticed it but
i was like
i i don't know i was just i was [ __ ]
sweating from like how much i was trying
to hold in this i thought i thought you
were like holding in the cough because
you didn't want to like [ __ ] yourself in
the process
just just do it i'm just be like i'm
gonna do it who who cares what are they
gonna do like it's not like a zombie
apocalypse why if you've been bitten
they're gonna kill you have you ever
coughed and [ __ ] at the same time no
mine's fine
no
we're not talking about [ __ ] yet
yeah
[Laughter]
of course i've done it okay i've never
done that
like i have also we've all done it we
haven't all done that
i have never done that unfortunately
joey yeah i'm so sorry i'm sorry
it's a it's a sensation
so are you on the toilet or yeah of
course i'm on the toilet okay that
doesn't count that doesn't yeah that's
what i meant like i don't mean like i'm
i'm not asking you to be like have you
shot yourself before like in public like
i think before i shut myself off we
talked about that yeah but uh yeah no
just like on the toilet and you just
like it's not coming out and then you
use the power of the cough to like
exhaust your body
so you're heavy you know what let's see
this is how you get hemorrhoids
i think the only thing that comes close
to that isn't like [ __ ] yourself but
like it's it's when you go back to the
gym for the first time in ages you have
like ab day or something and like the
day after your entire body aches and
like the one time you sneeze it just
like puts your entire body into like
pain mode
i literally did this like two weeks ago
yeah i was an ab day for the first time
in months yeah and not not one day it
was like five days afterwards yeah right
oh really yeah why was it lagging
no no it's in like for the next five
days oh like in a row
because then you went hard i just went
too hard man i just went too hard i
don't know what can i say update what
are you doing yeah talking about seasons
though like can japan chill with its
changing of seasons
um i i don't know like
it last week it felt like winter it felt
like it was coming on the like tail of
the winter it was like warming up a
little bit yeah and i think we had two
days of spring like spring weather and i
remember like going out yesterday or the
day before in this jacket and i was
sweating my ass off already and i just
like
japan i've just noticed it just it
doesn't have a transition period you
just wake up one day and it's a new
season they say japan has four seasons
what a lot of [ __ ] it's such a lie japan
has two seasons it's not it's hot it is
two yeah it's winter in summer that's
all they have it's it's it's like
different stages of cold and then just
different stages of hot there's no
warm there's no like warm period they
get like the warm period is maybe like
in the evening when like the sun's just
gone down and like the the residue of
like the concrete heat is like escaping
that's when it's like okay that's kind
of pleasant but then immediately
afterwards it's just like oh now it's
cold as [ __ ] because you're in a t-shirt
like an idiot i always forget how hot it
is until the summer comes and then i'm
like oh yeah this is this is hell yeah i
think it's like trauma for me yeah like
i like forget about it and yeah i'm like
what some of what
i'm winter game i'm wearing i'm wearing
a coat
and i forget that for half the year in
japan you just can't wear more than one
t-shirt yeah yeah exactly unless you're
a japanese person and you can wear a
it'd be like oh it's a little a little
dab of sweat right here what temperature
is in the office can we have 30 degrees
celsius please what yeah i don't know
like i don't know how i walk around in
the summer and just see like business
people in full-on suits carrick was like
running along that briefcase and i'm
here dying in my t-shirts and shorts
yeah i'm a sweater i'm a big sweater boy
i am i am like a [ __ ] i am it's
it's
i mean like i'm in the complete opposite
of sydney because she doesn't sweat
enough when it comes to heat like i i'd
like
we're deep in summer and like feel her
forehead and it's just like there's
there's zero there's zero perspiration
the same i'm like that's that's how you
get heat straight
and body's working yeah if you sweat a
lot that's healthy
yeah technically what is it but like it
just what do i get yeah i mean i mean i
mean
yeah
to me it's like it's a copium like it's
it's healthy it's healthy because like
i i feel like the tiniest bit of heat
and my armpits especially just a lot
just just start perspirating and there's
no way
like and like there's no way you don't
that doesn't ruin anything you [ __ ]
wear unfortunately so i just have to
like be worried in the summer even if
i'm not even if
even if i'm like underneath air
conditioning i still sweat sometimes i
mean it's weird i don't sweat through my
armpits as much and for me it's all in
the face which is horrible because you
can't hide that [ __ ] you're literally
like that meme of that that guy i don't
know he's like on the radio he's like
yes
i'm like that key and peel gift where
it's just like
wet
but like the rest of my body is okay i
hate it
but yeah i mean i guess that's why we're
from we're from england right i mean do
you feel like being british has
conditioned you to like cold weather or
do you feel like you've gotten used to
like
other climates i think it's the
temperature it's more so the sun i think
yeah where i'm allergic to the sun
is that because you're white yeah i know
very wide very wide very wide indeed but
like you know but i i would understand
because you know you guys have like that
lack of sun right in the uk but like in
australia we have like an overdose of
sun so i'm like i'm like also
traumatized by too much sun yeah as well
because in japan it's like you know
sometimes the sun works and then
sometimes it works overtime i still
think the summer was worse in the uk
than it was in japan because we don't
have we don't have ac oh yeah so it's
like it's like three four weeks of like
at least the last time i was there yeah
it was like three full weeks of just
uncomfortable sweating and now i can't
do anything yeah like
at least in japan i'm i can game all day
in a comfortable ac yeah climate room
right it's not yeah okay when i go
outside it sucks i i sweat but like i
take that over having a be in my bedroom
sweating and being able to do nothing
yeah sure that's like it's it's horrible
like you get one of those fans that
blows air but i feel like that's
literally like a copium like machine
yeah yeah it doesn't do anything you
just pull the air around it's just
blowing the hot air into my face
actually i actually like the fan like
sometimes like i think that's the
southeast asia i think it is i think
people like they love fans they're like
they i swear they're just like fans all
the time so to me you're like you you
admit defeat
if you are putting on the ac right that
means you are more weak than the weather
i don't know like the fan like i like
the feeling of like just hot like not
exactly cold out you say you're a fan
[ __ ] off joe [ __ ] up i don't know under
the ac because like to me the ac it just
feels like how can i put this it feels
like artificial air i get it i i can't
does that does that make sense no i
understand that the ac air is like not
one you want to be like breathing in i
don't know why it feels weird because it
i feel the same way about like heaters
right where if you if you have if
there's a difference in having like a
warm room and having a room that's been
warmed up by a heater right because it
feels ten times more stuffy for some
reason oh yeah um like i i don't like
the feeling of just the artificial heat
as opposed to just being in a country or
in a temperature that is comfortable
like naturally outside same thing with
ac for me with ac if you get if you have
a room that's cooled with ac it just
feels
i don't know like the air how can i
describe this it feels like it feels
sterile you know what i mean you know
what i mean
it feels it feels sterile it is first of
all problems well i agree i agree like
it just like i breathe within it's just
unnaturally dry
sometimes like my my asthma like my my
lungs feel the dry air way more with ac
air than uh than with like just cold air
in general i don't know it's
it's it's completely something that is
just a me issue but i might that's why i
much prefer having a fan as opposed to
having the ac